now let us all welcome the lovely long
leg Liddy for Manny and the brighten
stir from diner and ranking her cute and
Steve Guttenberg
thank you very much it's our privilege
to present the Oscar for best costume
designing film costumes have always
influenced the way the world presses and
after Annie Hall your next-door neighbor
well she looked just like Diane Keaton
it's true I told him he moved
movies established fashion trends and
women rushed to buy whatever they see on
the screen and even in newsreels you
remember when Queen Elizabeth was here
last month she wore that pretty polkadot
dress and that pretty polkadot P good
cap yes she look like a successful
jockey my Stephen you trying to tell me
you don't like the Queen's clothes
actually I I loved it but I don't think
Prince Philip did No
you notice how he always walks with his
hands clasped behind his back yes as if
to keep him from putting them over his
eyes my best achievement in costume
design the nominees honor John Marlowe
and Bono attire for Gandhi
Piero [ __ ] for La Traviata hmm rusty or
so Sophie's Choice annoys Jensen and
Rosana Norton for Tron and Patricia
Norris for victor/victoria I love this
place yeah you guys okay thank you
oh and the winners are John mallow and
van Wacha for Gandhi accepting the
costumes
it's too good to believe Thank You
Academy and thank you sir richard
attenborough for focusing well attention
on India